this is what remains of el jalee
abdullah's home in sudan's southeastern
blue nile state he's searching for any
personal belongings he can salvage most
were burned in fighting between members
of his hammock tribe and the hausang
sir
we were surprised on friday morning by
members of the hausa tribe attacking us
and burning property so we had to flee
my brother was killed right here we
found his body hacked to pieces
now we're homeless and the situation is
really tough
tension speaks when the hauser tried to
establish a tribal administration and
laid claim to land other tribes resisted
fighting broke out and left dozens dead
blue nile state has seen repeated
violence in the past decades with
fighting between government and rebel
forces resulting in mass displacements
while a peace deal was signed in 2020 to
end the violence the latest cycle of
tribal clashes seems to show that the
state is far from permanent stability
thousands have fled their homes and the
housing communities in several states
have protested against the violence some
tribal elders in blue nile believe it's
politically motivated
there are armed groups that want to
broaden their base in preparation for
elections and they thought that they can
mobilize tribes it's unfortunate the
houser responded we had repeatedly
called them not to be part of this but
they didn't listen
state authorities say the perpetrators
will be prosecuted
blue nile has long been a state with a
diverse group of tribes we urge all
citizens to not listen to rumors or
speeches that incite hate and anger and
to preserve unity between the residents
[Music]
algili wants those responsible for
burning down his home and killing his
brother held accountable but he says
he's not sure if justice will be enough
to end the anger and the violence hiba
morgan al-jazeera roseries in blue nile
state